racial persecution really isn't the
problem in Baltimore something else is
in play that's something else is
personal behavior all the pork and
Fergus earn and due to man-made liberals
that this never real protest this has
been organized by the typical suspects
all bad actors with that intent how
could I possibly say that oh I don't
know the leadership the Bloods the Crips
SEIU and the Nation of Islam rioters our
foot soldiers of the Democrat Party and
pawns of the New World Order paving a
path for the socialist revolution and
the final nail in the coffin that was
the American Republic bunch of violent
criminals who should be prosecuted as
adults they should be identified from
those tapes and there should be a
concerted effort to prosecute and put
them in prison to teach others not to do
that you need to break down the family
structure the lack of fathers the lack
of sort of a moral code in our society